it was amazing man trap karaoke this is
an experience like no other and I never
want to do regular ass karaoke again
after this before walking into trap
karaoke I had no idea what I was getting
myself into my cousin actually told me
about it she went to the show in Philly
a week before me and she was like yeah
I'm gonna try karaoke and I was like uh
karaoke was that she's like yeah girl
she's show me the Instagram page and
basically show me that it's a giant
concert and you can become your favorite
rapper singer for five minutes and hop
on the stage in front of hundreds and
hundreds of people and do karaoke on the
trap karaoke website it actually says in
the About section it says shout karaoke
is like going to church but instead of
Amazing Grace you're singing back that
ass up
[Music]
selecting a song I wanted to take a song
that everyone knew something that was
really popular or something that was
just like super hyped and full of life
when I could particularly jump up and
down on stage and swing my locks around
the show was Friday night at 9:00 p.m.
and I decided on a song at 2:00 p.m. on
Friday
I picked Waka Flocka no head it's a
classic thing my best friend Danny he's
actually I theme song for freshman year
so it was only right that I had her come
through and be my height man I thought I
knew all the words to that song and the
only thing I know is a goddamn chorus
wasn't so I spent the whole day the
whole entire day listening to no hands
honor people just watching the lyrics
video on repeat on repeat no hands
that's the only song unless I hate it
now
let's live it down I'm super excited I
can't wait Danny's ready right Danny I'm
ready the environment and trap karaoke
walking into there was literally like
walking into a giant barbecue it felt
like everyone was your cousin just for
the love of music and a love of black
music and black culture it was just it
was beautiful to be in that room below
that many people and everyone had
different graphic t-shirts that said
things about trap music
they let us hang out backstage before
the performance so me and Danny got him
a little last-minute practice we were
going so hard to put on the perfect
performance so we practiced the words
again we practice everything practice it
who's practicing the different words
when you're sitting there
we kept tripping over our word or you're
definitely nervous in the back freaking
out man freaking out for no reason I am
nervous when they told me I was an X I
pen
all I could hear was the crowd I swear
my heart started racing when I heard
them call my name it was my time so I
just swallowed my nerves and ran out
there
[Applause]
today the units on the ground what's it
gonna do
[Applause]
[Applause]
when the crowd went crazy after I said I
was doing no hands I know that was
exactly the energy I needed to help me
get through the performance I didn't
realize how many people were out there
until I got on stage but I tried to
ignore that and be blind about all the
lights the energy in the adrenaline I
was hyped up hell I was so - when I was
sitting there I was rapping I felt like
I really embraced waka and you could
really tell I was in the zone like I
just said gentlemen I don't even know
what to do I have so much Andy I don't
even know where to start I was just like
where do I start where do I go which
part of stays do I jump off first I was
just trying to sell my performance by
jumping around the stage with Danny
Danny was killing it Danny had so much
energy she was dancing all over the
stage anyone else and Danny just threw
her whole thing of cash and I was like
ah they stressed to me that I had to
know all the words in this song and I
really underestimated that you get
kicked off stage if you don't know the
lyrics when they drop the beat one of my
biggest fears is probably getting kicked
on stage from not knowing the words I
brought fake money to distract people
from me not knowing the words I had
girls come onstage and twerk while I was
rapping let's cut that in other words
and then my jump in long dreads and
dancing didn't help out of it
not enough distractions so guests will
look like a fool on stage this guy
[Applause]
leave your city make some noise with
genius tonight please
[Applause]
that was amazing oh man like I felt like
it was mad it was like advanced energy
so money magnet any GM said that in his
nervous as we was like even with us now
even though all the words like the crowd
was like the crowd was ready where I was
amazing
there was everything y'all couldn't find
me because she was just but you a lot of
states gone in Rome I don't do it again
am i doing it right now of course let's
go let's go I think they're enough cuz I
mean I felt let me put on a got damn
good performer Z it was a paper hey my
dougie I would do it ten times ten times
more
[Music]